Remember Jurassic Park?
Those guys were so silly.
if they wanted to see dinosaurs, just go outside.
They're BIRDS NOW!
Hey raptors, Trace here for DNews.
Dinosaurs are of constant fascination to humans
all over the planet.
150 million years ago, birds were giant animals
roaming free across the planet, until 65 million
years ago, when that big asteroid hit causing
a massive extinction across the entirety of
our planet.
Obviously, our ancient mammalian ancestors
were able to survive, as were many other animals
-- mostly by burrowing into the ground or
hiding in the water to escape the initial
heat, and then surviving on smaller prey during
the ensuing years of cold.
The big fellas like diplodocus would never
have survived -- they couldn't seek shelter
and needed far too much food.
But, according to new research published in
the journal Science, some dinosaurs DID survive,
the smaller ones.
Scientists at the University of Adelaide analyzed
the skeletal characteristics of 1,500 dinosaurs
over 50-million years and found theropods
-- a carnivorous dinosaur family which included
tyrannosaurus -- got smaller, and smaller
over that time.
In fact, they got smaller in 12 separate mutations,
going from 163 kilos on average to the 0.8
kilo Archaeopteryx, the first bird.
Because they kept getting smaller, and because
they ate meat rather than plant life, they
were able to survive the asteroid strike and
ensuing extinction.
The reason meat eaters survived was because
they didn't require as large a body as plant
eaters -- less body means less to take care
of which means survival!
Yay!
Separate research, also published in Science
last month, theorizes that ALL dinosaurs had
feathers, some were more primitive, more like
hairs or bristles, while others were soft
and downy like modern birds.
They discovered this when they found a new
dinosaur called Kulindadromeus zabaikalicus
which had feathers, but couldn't fly.
This, combined with other evidence is enough
to make a theory, but not a final determination.
Though, taken together, it's pretty easy to
see that modern birds are probably tiny dinosaurs,
and the scientists were quoted in the Washington
Post saying, "Without a doubt," that is the
case.
But why would these dinosaurs get smaller?
What would be the purpose?
Scientists say there would be a distinct advantage.
Smaller carnivorous dinosaurs with feathers
would be able to climb trees, glide, and MAYBE
fly -- allowing them to hunt prey that differed
from their larger carnivorous brethren, also
helping them survive extinction.
"They just knew how to innovate, evolutionarily
speaking," Discovery News writer Richard Farrell
said.
If you take this to be true, as many paleontologists
today do, then instead of being extinct, there
are 10,000 species of dinosaur living and
breathing on our planet still today, even
more than there are mammals or reptiles!
Maybe had some fried dinosaur for dinner last
night, or went out to fill the dinosaur-feeder
in your yard or perhaps you have a pet dinosaur
in a cage in your house…
All of those sound pretty frickin' cool to
me.
What do you think?
Are you on board with the dinosaur-bird changeover?
Are you going to start calling it KFD or eat
dinosaur noodle soup when you’re sick?
Make your own jokes down in the comments and
subscribe to our channel for more DNews!
We post all day on Facebook, Twitter and GooglePlus
-- and make two videos every day of the week.
Thank you so much for watching!